in hiding and desperate this former
interpreter and his family
begged to be moved to the uk he says a
year spent working with british forces
in afghanistan
means a lifetime of fear from the
taliban
in the coming months taliban will get me
so as soon as possible they will find me
they will slam me
so they will slaughter and beheaded me
and my family
the anxiety seems well-founded as the
taliban gains ground
here evidence of heavy fighting in the
capital of northern afghanistan's kunduz
province
the central market destroyed
this city now largely in taliban hands
their flag in the main square a
significant win following a decision
by the united states and allies to
withdraw their troops from the country
but growing security concerns have
prompted the uk government
to fly more than a thousand former
interpreters
other staff and families to safety in
the last few weeks alone
these the latest to arrive under a new
more generous resettlement scheme but a
group of more than 40 former commanders
has urged the prime minister to go
further
they say people like n whose name we're
not disclosing to protect his identity
have been rejected from the scheme just
because they were sacked from their
interpreting jobs
and not because they posed a security
risk when
i see they rejected me bad feeling
happened to me
i i can tell you in reality that
i can't control myself in that time
because
lots of my friends they fly to uk
recently
this is him during his time spent with
troops in the southern province of
helmand in 2011.
he says he lost his job for smoking
drugs and stealing
crimes he says he didn't commit and
there was no chance to appeal
a ministry of defense spokesperson said
we carefully assess
each application for relocation those
who were dismissed for serious offences
including those that constitute a crime
in the uk
will continue to be excluded but the
taliban won't care whether someone like
n was sacked or not
they view anyone who worked with british
forces as a traitor
i should receive the same help from
uk to
rescue me and my family so if
does not happen so my message is clear
that
this honor this honor shame
[Music]
will be squarely on the feet of uk
government and uk nations
save our life uk for now
all he can do is hope the uk hears their
voice
and has a change of heart debra haines
sky news